[Music]
dave rubin is the author of the
fantastic new book don't burn this book
it came out today we're happy to have
him on tonight Dave thanks so much for
coming on tonight do you good good to
have you do you notice that the norms
and standards to quote the Atlantic of
American life seems to have changed
overnight and all of a sudden we're
being told we must accept things that
would have been completely unimaginable
two months ago well Tucker there's so
much to talk about here first off I
didn't realize I was going to be on a
sci-fi show tonight but we are and
during a distant future we are entering
an authoritarian future because as I've
said to you before authoritarians love
authoritarianism so they're taking this
opportunity when we're all confused
we're all locked at home the only way we
can communicate with each other is
through their pipes is through YouTube
and Facebook and Twitter and everything
else and they're actually finally saying
to us this is who we are I mean the
Atlantic is ridiculous I don't know
anyone that reads it anymore but but the
bigger issue here is is the YouTube
Twitter Facebook component of it because
we are now saying to them or or they're
saying to us we're gonna tell you what's
true and if you dare go against what we
say is true not necessarily what is true
but what we say is true then we're gonna
boot you so the the of course the other
part of this is that it will always only
be one side that gets booted here I mean
is Facebook running around and is
Twitter and YouTube running around are
they taking away all the Russian
collusion videos that were up over the
past couple years a pretty sure MSNBC
has a YouTube channel that still has
videos on it I mean that was pushing
lies and misinformation and propaganda
so we need to debate these things if I
was to interview these two doctors that
you show the video of would my channel
be deleted am I not allowed to talk
about that is that not what science and
open inquiry really is about that you
test theories and then you find out what
actually is true and as you
pointed out and this may be the most
important part it's not as if the w-h-o
is infallible they were literally just a
few weeks ago telling us not to wear
masks now by law I tried to go to CBS
yesterday and I wasn't going to wear a
mask I was just gonna run in and out and
it said in the front of the store it
said by law you have to wear a mask so
it's not as if these people have some
you know some total stranglehold on
truth that the rest of us have to bow to
unless they force us to and
unfortunately big tech has got us now
more than ever because we're all trapped
at home and it's the only way we can
communicate so no one in science has a
monopoly on the truth science in fact as
a rejection of the idea that there is a
monopoly on truth it's the endless
search for what we can prove that's what
science is they this has nothing to do
with it you introduces a hypothetical
the notion that you could be deleted
your channel for hosting this video I'm
not sure that is hypothetical anymore
and my question is very simple how long
before they come for you
you just sort of book called don't burn
this book how long before they come for
the show sincere questions yeah well I
at some level I don't want to think
about it but you know Tucker you've
written a couple books and you know that
the publishing process takes quite some
time so I finished this book back in
July but I'm very proud that the ideas
that I present and don't burn this book
are more relevant now than they even
were then because I talk about big tech
I talk about fake news all of the things
that we're constantly talking about and
am I worried yeah I'm worried I mean
look anyway everyone should be worried
everyone should be worried this is why I
started locals calm my tech company
because I think we need digital homes
anyone that's online and you think that
YouTube or Facebook or Twitter is there
to protect you you're the product I mean
these things are free accept free
meaning they just took your soul in
exchange for it we should own our data
you should own your own content we need
to start rethinking everything I mean I
think this is why I'm actually quite
enthused about the world right now is as
depressing and upsetting as some of the
news is you know there's a new world
coming on the horizon and I think a lot
of people are rethinking the way they
look at the world the way do you want to
commute do you want to live in a big
city do you want to be sold
iein on the institutions and systems
that we've always been relying on so I
think we have to rethink things and you
know what Tucker this is still America
for a little while and I believe in
old-fashioned hard work and competition
in jindo and ingenuity and I think
that's what will fix this but yeah we're
we got a we got a big battle to fight in
front of us yeah and and maybe some cook
I mean these companies exist because
Congress gave them a carve out in
federal legislation and you sort of
wonder where is Senator Mike Lee on this
question sucking up to Google did great
to see you tonight